la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur chers
collègues notre ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direct sur Public Sénat
et notre site internet chacun sera
Atlantique au respect des uns les autres
au respect du temps de parole et
immédiatement je donne la parole au
président Hervé Marseille pour le groupe
de l'Union centrée
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues avec mes
collègues j'ai souhaité attirer votre
attention sur un sujet qui nous
préoccupe gravement c'est notre relation
avec les pays du Maghreb et en
particulier avec le Maroc
cette relation avec un pays historique
et dégradé nous y étions il y a peu avec
le président Combon et une délégation du
groupe d'amitié et nous avons pu mesurer
l'état de dégradation de la relation
entre la France et le Maroc nous sommes
pas reçus par le Mans dans les
ministères on est reçu dans les parties
ou à domicile même si ces chaleureux et
donc on voit bien que depuis deux ans
le Maroc qui est un pays ami
historiquement depuis longtemps où nous
avons beaucoup d'intérêt et qui
constitue nos yeux et nos oreilles dans
cette région et bien
est en difficulté dans sa relation avec
la France alors cette relation elle
n'est pas exclusive de ce que nous
pouvons faire de façon équilibrée avec
l'Algérie ça c'est fait pendant
plusieurs années de nombreuses années
nous avons consenti de gros efforts en
direction de l'Algérie président de la
République s'y rendu peu de temps après
madame la Première ministre vous y êtes
allé avec une grande délégation force
est de constater que c'est renoncement
finalement que nous avons consenti ont
été peu couronnés de succès si j'en
crois les dernières mesures du
gouvernement algérien qui a cru de voir
réintroduire un couplet assez peu amical
en direction de la France dans l'hymne
national
et bien
président de la République a reçu hier
madame Meloni
ce qui existe entre l'Italie ce qui
existe avec le Maroc et l'Algérie c'est
l'Union européenne c'est l'Union
Méditerranéenne pardon et l'Union pour
la Méditerranée est en rade il y a pas
d'autres mots depuis plusieurs années
maintenant depuis longtemps maintenant
et donc il est indispensable que pour
affirmer la place de la France en
Méditerranée pour que nous puissions
engager un dialogue utile sur les
problèmes migratoires et pesés au sein
de l'Union européenne il est
indispensable que nous puissions
relancer cette Union pour la
Méditerranée et que nous puissions
travailler à nouveau dans des conditions
de confiance avec le Maroc parce que les
Marocains sont nos amis au Maghreb donc
madame la Première ministre
quelles initiatives pardon quelle
initiative comptez-vous prendre pour
relancer l'Union pour la Méditerranée et
les relations avec le Maroc
merci
pour vos réponses à madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le président Hervé Marseille
la France a une relation très riche une
histoire partagée et des liens humains
particulièrement étroits avec le Maroc
comme avec l'Algérie
une histoire de cette intensité n'est
jamais dépassionnée et je veux le redire
nous avons un objectif clair
développer et approfondir nos liens dans
le respect mutuel avec chacun des deux
pays avec l'Algérie nous continuons à
travailler dans l'esprit de la
déclaration d'Alger pour un partenariat
renouvelé entre la France et l'Algérie
vous l'avez dit je me suis moi-même
rendu à Alger en octobre 2022 quelques
semaines après la visite du président de
la République pour qu'au présider le
Comité intergouvernemental de haut
niveau les deux présidents de la
République échangent de façon très
régulière nous souhaitons aller de
l'avant il y a bien sûr des obstacles
mais surtout il y a une volonté une
volonté commune partagée par le
président Macron et le président teboun
de regarder vers l'avenir et de
construire au bénéfice de nos deux
peuples nous restons bien évidemment
vigilants notamment dans le domaine
migratoire nous avons sur ce sujet
un dialogue exigeant en particulier sur
la réadmission des ressortissants
algériens en situation irrégulière
avec le Maroc nos liens sont très forts
qu'ils soient humains économique ou
culturelles la relation franco-marocaine
ce sont par exemple plus de 46 000
étudiants marocains en France
46000 élèves dans les établissements
français au Maroc et plus de 1000
filiales d'entreprises françaises la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères Catherine Colonna s'est rendu
au Maroc en décembre dernier pour une
visite très positive le souhait de la
France est de poursuivre
l'approfondissement de ce partenariat
d'exception au service des intérêts que
partage nos deux pays et à la hauteur de
la relation que nous voulons avec le
Maroc et vous avez raison monsieur le
Président Marseille l'avenir de nos
relations avec l'Algérie et le Maroc
comme avec la Tunisie s'inscrit plus
largement dans notre politique pour la
Méditerranée la France est à l'origine
de l'Union pour la Méditerranée elle
continuera à prendre à prendre des
initiatives fortes
pour renforcer les liens entre les deux
rives et pour apporter ensemble des
réponses concrètes à nos défis communs
notamment en matière d'environnement je
vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Cathy a
poursu poli pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste
le président monsieur le ministre chers
collègues les assises des finances
publiques que vous attendiez comme un
moment fort de ce quinquennat est en
réalité un nouveau rendez-vous manqué
dans votre volonté de considérer la voix
des collectivités territoriales
l'Association des Maires l'Assemblée des
départements des régions de France ont
refusé de participer à cette grande
messe ils ont eu raison selon vous ce
sont de nouveau les collectivités
territoriales qui devront faire des
efforts pour désendetter la France on
parle ici de 10 à 15 milliards d'euros
vous leur demandez de réduire de 0,5
leurs dépenses de fonctionnement alors
qu'elles sont déjà en difficulté les
budgets des collectivités 2023 ont été
construits dans une extrême fragilité et
ceux de 2014 le seront encore plus les
mers les présidents d'agglo les
présidentes communautés de communes nous
expliquent qu'ils n'ont jamais eu autant
de mal à boucler leur budget aujourd'hui
les municipalités ne disposent même plus
de leviers fiscaux pour assurer des
recettes pérennes suppression de la taxe
d'habitation suivi d'une suppression de
la cave à coup de 49.3 comme si ce
n'était pas suffisant vous augmentez le
point d'indice des fonctionnaires
territoriaux c'est une bonne nouvelle
mais une fois de plus sans aucune
compensation financière de l'État ce
sont les services rendus à la population
et la libre administration des communes
que vous impactez par vos décisions vous
êtes incapable de travailler avec les
collectivités territoriales sur des
sujets qui affectent leur quotidien y
compris de dialoguer avec celles et ceux
qui chaque jour sont sur le terrain je
parle des élus locaux vous leur demandez
d'agir en faveur de la transition
écologique mais vous leur demandez de
dépenser moins que l'inflation chaque
année c'est réduire les chances de
répondre aux enjeux de développement
durable monsieur le ministre quand
allez-vous vous quand allez-vous mettre
en place un réel pacte financier entre
l'État et les collectivités
territoriales afin de garantir le
service public et de prendre en compte
les réalités locales je vous remercie
pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre délégué chargé
des comptes publics monsieur Attal
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
madame la sénatrice Cathy
c'est le Ministre des comptes publics
qui vous répond mais c'est aussi les
locales je suis conseiller municipal
dans ma commune depuis près de 10 ans
maintenant et je le dis pourquoi je le
dis parce que ce mandat local me permet
d'avoir une conviction absolue c'est
qu'on ne peut pas opposer l'État et les
collectivités locales que les
collectivités locales ont évidemment
besoin de l'État notamment dans des
périodes de crise pour être accompagnés
que l'État a besoin des collectivités
locales pour que l'investissement se
maintienne un bon niveau dans notre pays
et qu'on a tous besoin les uns des
autres pour relever le grand défi de la
transition écologique qui nécessitera un
investissement public massif raison pour
laquelle nous devons avancer ensemble et
avancer ensemble y compris sur la
maîtrise de nos dépenses publiques parce
que quand nous nous retrouvons dans une
situation de tension sur les finances
publiques que les taux d'intérêts
augmentent ça a un impact évidemment
pour les finances de l'État mais ça
aussi un impact pour les collectivités
local notamment dans leur projet
d'investissement avec des taux d'intérêt
qui augmentent et qui impacte leur
projet d'investissement et donc c'est
tous ensemble que nous devons aussi être
capables de relever ce défi celui de
garder le contrôle sur nos finances
publiques on avait présenté un programme
de stabilité une loi de programmation
des finances publiques l'an dernier avec
Bruno Le Maire qui prévoyait un effort
sur les cinq ans à venir supérieur pour
les collectivités locales par rapport à
celui de l'État on a eu un grand nombre
de débats ici dans cette hémicycle on a
entendu ce qui était émis notamment par
les sénatrices et les sénateurs la
nouvelle copie du programme de stabilité
que nous avons présenté prévoit
l'inverse un effort supérieur pour
l'État par rapport aux collectivités
locales -08% pour l'État versus moins
0,5% sur les dépenses de fonctionnement
en volume pour les collectivités locales
ensuite il nous appartient de construire
ensemble les mécanismes et la manière
dont nous avons nous allons avancer nous
avons reçu les associations d'élus il y
a eu trois réunions encore dans les
semaines récentes au niveau technique
nous les avons su au niveau ministériel
nous allons continuer à avancer avec
elle avec un objectif avancer ensemble
au service du pays et encore une fois
des investissements que nous aurons à
faire pour la transition écologique et
une méthode celle de la course je vous
remercie merci la parole est de notre
collègue Dominique Théophile pour le
groupe du Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre des Outre-mer
monsieur le ministre la Guadeloupe
s'apprête à affronter une hausse du
trafic aérien notamment avec les
vacances estivales s'il s'agit bien
d'une aubaine pour notre territoire
après deux ans de crise covid une
nouvelle difficulté s'ajoute et perturbe
d'ores et déjà les usagers de l'aéroport
pour le Caraïbes monsieur le ministre
notre aéroport fait face à une pénurie
de contrôleur aérien en effet faute
d'effectif suffisant l'aéroport Pôle
Caraïbes principal plateforme reliant
notre territoire avec le monde en
matière de transport de personnes
infrastructures essentielles en matière
de continuité territoriale pour notre
région sera fermée du 23 au 25 juin une
fermeture que nous avons déjà connue les
21 et 22 février dernier
l'aéroport dispose à ce jour de néfectif
de 24 agents dont 19 sont totalement
opérationnels alors que 31 postes sont
nécessaires afin d'assurer un
fonctionnement dit normal les
conséquences sont graves et importantes
avec des vols et liés rotations
reportées des passagers non cheminés et
parfois des évacuations sanitaires
annulées face à l'urgence de la
situation les réponses ne sont pas au
rendez-vous notre territoire ne peut pas
attendre la formation de nouveaux
contrôleur d'ici 18 mois d'autres
alternatives sont envisageables telles
que la recherche sur le plan au plan
national d'autres agents le transfert
d'effectif à partir de plateformes
proches comme Fort de France
ou la mutualisation des effectifs entre
la Guadeloupe et la Martinique aussi
monsieur le ministre dans un contexte
exceptionnel et pour prévenir d'autres
perturbations qui pourraient s’avérer
plus graves en matière de sécurité le
gouvernement pourrait-il mettre en place
des mesures d'urgence afin de renforcer
les effectifs de contrôleur aérien
Guadeloupe et puis pourriez-vous nous
les préciser
merci pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre déléguée en charge les
outre-mer Monsieur Jean-François caraco
désolé
c'est l'actrice et sénateur monsieur le
créateur Théophile vous interrogez le
gouvernement sur la pénurie d'effective
des contrôleurs aériens et notamment
aussi sur son impact sur la sécurité
civile en Guadeloupe
sur place et si nouveau contrôleur
aérien de pas arriver d'ici la rentrée
et non pas dans 18 mois je m'en suis
entretenu ce matin même avec le DGAC le
ministre délégué au transport travaille
par ailleurs des mesures de fidélisation
d'optimisation des temps de formation
locale cette situation n'affectant rien
la sécurité et je pense que d'ici
quelques semaines elle devrait
s'améliorer pour les vols civils
merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Vincent et Blais pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
monsieur le Président chers collègues
j'associe rachidemale sénateur du
Val-d'Oise à ma question madame la
Première ministre a avoué l'indique le
gouvernement n'avait pas suffisamment
associé les collectivités territoriales
sur la question du point d'indice en
effet cette décision impose aux
assemblées locales dans le budget voté
depuis le 15 avril de revoir leur copie
deux mois après cette méthode est un
manque de considération notoire
vis-à-vis des élus locaux d'autant plus
irritants que le coût est loin d'être
anodin annoncé à un milliard le matin de
l'annonce ce montant à doubler
l'après-midi
depuis 2017 les décisions imposées sont
nombreuses suppression de la TH contre
la vie des associations contrat de
Cahors et loi de programmation par
lesquelles vous imposez 13 milliards
d'économies augmentation du point
d'indice dès 2022 sans plus de
consultation ni de compensation
qu'aujourd'hui plan d'eau plan vélo
annoncé unilatéralement et vous laissez
les élus locaux assumez seul la mise en
œuvre la liste pourrait s'allonger mais
le temps manque le gouvernement a
démontré son incapacité à contenir le
déficit public et en même temps vous
demandez aux collectivités de participer
à un plan d'économie de 10 milliards que
vous savez l'état incapable de réaliser
le ministre chargé des collectivités
s'inquiéter en février dernier de la
frilosité à investir devant les
conséquences de l'inflation et en même
temps contradiction le ministre de
l'Économie propose la mise en place de
l'auto-assurance qui va mettre en danger
l'investissement local nous devons
parler enfin réellement des prélèvements
obligatoires de leur niveau de leur
assiette et de leur pertinence notamment
pour recréer un lien entre les
industries et les territoires et en même
temps vous élevez un totem à la baisse
des impôts et lancer des populistes
balance ton maire ou encore en avoir
pour mes impôts qui mettent en danger le
consentement même à l'impôt que
comptez-vous mettre en place pour
répondre enfin à l'exigence de justice
pour les territoires merci
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole des
communistes déléguées en charge des
comptes publics monsieur Attal non
monsieur bichu
mais nous sommes ravis accueillir
monsieur Béchu pour pour une réponse
aussi simple voilà
monsieur le Président d'abord en vous
remerciant pour la mansuétude avec
laquelle vous avez accepté que je
supplay Gabriel Attal pour répondre à
cette question et ensuite pour saluer la
haute assemblée et le sénateur est blé
la question du rapport entre les
collectivités locales et l'État n'est
pas nouvelle monsieur le sénateur et
quand vous pointez
les marges d'amélioration que nous avons
en termes de dialogue beaucoup ici se
souviennent que le totem de la baisse
des dotations qui a été porté par des
gouvernements que vous avez soutenus
entre 2012 et 2017 avec conduit dans des
conditions bien plus considérables à
moindre et le niveau des collectivités
territoriales
ensuite
vous évoquez un certain nombre de sujets
qui de mon point de vue doivent être
distingués
d'abord sur la hausse du point chaque
année la difficulté à trouver un
dispositif dès lors que c'est l'État qui
détermineuse du point qui vaut pour
toutes les fonctions publiques et que
nous n'avons pas dans notre pays jusqu'à
maintenant considérer qu'il pourrait y
avoir des trajectoires distinctes sur
les fonctions publiques en fonction des
employeurs conduit à ce qu'on est
systématiquement ce scénario dans lequel
il y a un dispositif qui est proposé par
l'État dans la consultation en coulisses
il est rare que les collectivités
s'opposent à des revalorisations de
points qui permettent de compenser
l'inflation ayant ensuite un jeu de
demande de compensation budgétaire mais
je ne pense pas que vos propos étaient
une manière de regretter le 1,5%
d'augmentation au 1er juillet du
traitement des fonctionnaires de ce pays
dans le contexte que nous connaissons
alors puisque je sais que derrière
l'artifice de la présentation que vous
avez choisi il y a une question plus
sérieuse sur le niveau de dialogue entre
l'État et les collectivités
territoriales je veux vous dire que ce
rendez-vous il approche il approche dans
le cadre précisément de la planification
écologique et de la réunion que j'ai eu
l'honneur de présider à la demande de la
première ministre avec toutes les
associations d'élus sur comment au titre
de la planification le mouvement qui va
constituer à donner aux collectivités
les moyens d'accélérer sur l'atténuation
et sur l'adaptation doit se faire quel
partage de responsabilité et de
contraintes et vous y serez évidemment
en tant que sénateur associé
[Applaudissements]
les collectivités ne veulent plus des
transferts de compétences sans
concertation et sans compensation
surtout quand il y a de l'inflation
monsieur le ministre elle demande plus
d'autonomie elles ne veulent pas de
discours condescendants de l'État elles
exigent son soutien pour affronter les
besoins et les difficultés du quotidien
pas de réponse sur ce point les
collectivités et les élus demandent plus
de respect et plus de considération
merci
mais la parole de madame la Présidente
Nathalie de la pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
insupportables et le premier mot qui
vient à l'esprit pour qualifier
l'ignoble attaque subit avant-hier par
une famille bordelaise mes pensées vont
vers cette petite fille sa grand-mère et
leur famille après l'agression dont
elles ont été victimes en rentrant à
leur domicile
mais remerciements vont aux forces de
l'ordre pour l'interpellation rapide
mais qualifiée de difficile de
l'agresseur
se faire agresser ça arrive à tout le
monde moi aussi ça m'est arrivé c'est la
réponse sidérante apporter lors d'une
réunion publique de celle du adjointe au
maire de Bordeaux il y a quelques jours
banalisant l'explosion de la sécurité
dans notre ville
je pourrais alors vous questionner
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur une
fois encore sur l'absolu nécessité
d'affecter une unité de CRS à demeure à
Bordeaux je pourrais monsieur le garder
ce vous réinterrogez sur la suspension
récente des incarcérations des hommes au
centre pénitentiaire de Gradignan en
raison de la surpopulation carcérale
laissant ainsi des individus dangereux
sur la voie publique même si un nombre
conséquent de détenus se retrouve en
prison alors que ces derniers
nécessiterait avant tout d'être admis
dans des hôpitaux psychiatriques c'est
donc vers vous monsieur le ministre de
la Santé que je me tourne une fois de
plus j'avais initié ici une mission avec
mes collègues Philippe Bas et Jean-Sol
sur l'expertise psychiatrique en matière
pénale tant notre société sont acte
républicain police justice sont de plus
en plus menacées par la sous-estimation
des problèmes psychiatriques souvent
couplées à des addictions liées à la
drogue l'effet divers quotidien en
atteste malheureusement
il faut de nouveaux hôpitaux
psychiatriques il faut une politique sur
la psychiatrie ambitieuse et financée je
vous demandais il y a quelques semaines
ici qu'elles deviennent grandes causes
nationales combien de drames faudra-t-il
égrainer pour vous en convaincre je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole et
commise de la santé de la prévention
monsieur Braun
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
satrices Delattre comme vous je tiens
tout d'abord à exprimer ma solidarité
celle du gouvernement tout entier envers
les victimes de cette odieuse agression
et je sais que l'ensemble des
parlementaires partage ce sentiment
vous avez cité mes collègues messieurs
Darmanin et du pomoretti vous avez
raison parce que nous travaillons de
concerts sur l'autorité de la première
ministre sur ce problème qui est global
global parce que nous faisons aussi face
à un problème de société problème de
société de rapport à l'autre de civilité
de rapport à la violence
face à cela nous devons mobiliser tous
les outils en les en particulier notre
capacité bien sûr à identifier à traiter
les problèmes psychiatriques ou
psychologiques le système de santé
présente des difficultés oui nous le
savons le système de la psychiatrie
également suite à des décennies de
gestion comptable aveugle pour autant
des 2018 nous avons agi en lançant une
feuille de route ambitieuse sur la santé
mentale et la psychiatrie qui a été
renforcée en 2021 par les premières
Assises de la santé mentale et de la
psychiatrie présidée est lancée par le
Président de la République les réponses
que nous construisons en priorité
s'inscrivent aussi il faut savoir dans
du temps long je pense par exemple au
développement de la prévention au
développement aujourd'hui des 43000
secouristes en santé mentale le
développement des compétences
psychosociales à l'école les actions de
prévention du suicide le numéro 31 14
plus de 300 000 appels depuis sa
création le dispositif vigilance la
prise en charge également de plus de 130
000 patients grâce à mon soutien psy
300.000 le développement des centres
médico-psychologiques des maisons des
adolescents désormais une par
département depuis un peu moins d'un an
et qui ont accompagné plus de 100 000
adolescents en difficulté avec leur
famille tout ça bien sûr n'est pas
suffisant au regard des enjeux que tous
les pays développés rencontrent en
matière de santé mentale soyez en tout
cas assurés de ma détermination à agir
sans faille avec l'ensemble des
professionnels et je ne sais l'ensemble
des parlementaires pour trouver des
solutions assez difficultés sur la santé
mentale
la parole est à notre collègue Daniel
salmon pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Le Bourget serait-il le salon
de l'illusion le salon de l'avion
magique on y voit depuis lundi
l'ensemble de la filière aéronautique et
le Président nous annonçait un avion
propre un avion vert pour demain ou
après-demain bien entendu la recherche
d'alternative au kérosène est
indispensable et l'on doit y mettre les
moyens là où le bât blesse c'est dans le
message qui est véhiculé ne changeons
pas les habitudes la technologie va tout
régler la sobriété d'usage est
complètement inexistante dans le
discours bien pire on parle de
doublement du trafic d'ici 2040
avion électrique avion à hydrogène avion
biocarburant sont présentés le problème
est que l'électrique pour les moyens est
longue courriers n'est pas pour demain
que l'avion à hydrogène est loin d'être
mature et pose encore d'énormes défis
technologiques que la biomasse
nécessaire au biocarburant n'est pas
illimité car il faudra dommage choisir
entre les avions les portes containers
les camions chauffer les logements et se
nourrir un bon greenwashing qui n'a
d'autre but que de remettre à deux mains
ce que nous devons faire dès aujourd'hui
c'est à dire réguler le secteur aérien
stopper sa croissance et lui faire payer
le prix de sa pollution monsieur le
ministre accorde des solutions
politiques maintenant afin que la
trajectoire du transport aérien soit
conforme à nos engagements de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
merci
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la transition écologique
mais de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur Christophe Béchu
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur salmon
je ne peux pas croire à l'instant que
dans vos propos il y a le regret qui est
la recherche d'aller vers un avion qui
soit moins émetteur je ne peux pas
croire à l'instant qui est dans vos
propos l'arrière-pensée de vous dire que
pour rendre l'écologie populaire il
convient de la présenter sous son jour
le plus punitif et je ne peux pas croire
un instant qu'il y ait dans vos propos
le regret que nous accueillons en ce
moment dans notre pays le plus grand
salon aéronautique du monde et que ce
salon soit précisément consacré au moyen
de faire en sorte de décarboner
l'aviation
à partir de ce moment-là
trois choses simples
la trajectoire de décarbonation dans
tous les domaines elle s'appuie toujours
sur un triptyque vouloir
ne retenir qu'un de ces trois piliers
c'est manquer à l'équilibre dont nous
avons besoin il faut de la sobriété il
faut de l'efficacité et il faut de
l'innovation si une partie des gens
explique que il faut condamner
l'innovation et qu'on y arrivera que par
la sobriété et que d'autres disent qu'il
ne faut rien changer à nos usages et
qu'on n'y arrivera par l'innovation ces
deux chemins nous emmènent dans le mur
très concrètement la sobriété c'est
d'abord le fait que nous sommes le
premier pays avoir interdit les vols de
moins de 2h30 quand il existe une
alternative en train
ensuite la sobriété c'est de faire en
sorte de privilégier le train de relever
la fiscalité sur le kérosène comme nous
l'avons fait l'année dernière pour
éviter d'avoir un avantage fiscal sur le
kérosène par rapport à l'essence et ce
sont les 100 milliards d'euros
d'investissement dans le ferroviaire
pour qu'il y ait des alternatives
crédible et à l'heure l'efficacité c'est
la baisse du poids c'est l'évolution des
moteurs avec un enjeu qui n'est pas
seulement national parce qu'il y a non
seulement les émissions françaises mais
dans les 3% des missions mondiales 50%
de ses émissions mondiales sont faites à
partir d'avions qui sont fabriqués en
Europe donc l'impact de l'innovation il
aura lieu partout ça n'est pas un
gouvernement qui décide du doublement du
trafic ce sont les prévisions sur la
base des décisions des individus et des
habitants de cette planète les deux axes
d'innovation annoncés par le Président
de la République ils sont simples
travailler sur les moteurs travailler
effectivement sur des alternatives en
termes de carburant et j'insiste devant
vous pour pas que ce soit caricaturer il
s'agit pas de prendre des terres
agricoles pour cultiver les
biocarburants il s'agit d'aller faire
des savent des carburants durables à
partir des résidus de bois d'algues ou
d'huile usag ées
[Applaudissements]
que seulement
monsieur le ministre c'est dommage vous
n'avez pas écouté mon introduction je
vous ai pourtant clairement dit que la
recherche était indispensable à vous
caricaturer c'est très facile mais par
contre ce qui est irresponsable c'est de
faire mine que la technologie va nous
sauver la sobriété dans les usages c'est
indispensable et on doit commencer par
cela le monde que vous nous préparez
c'est un monde à plus 4 degrés un monde
dont personne ne sait à quoi il va
ressembler il faut vraiment aller de
l'avant c'est ce qu'on attend de vous et
les politiques ça sert à cela ce n'est
pas de reporter à demain ce qui peut
être fait aujourd'hui
la parole est à notre collègue Emmanuel
Capu
pour le gros plaisirs
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre lundi se tenait les assises de
Bercy
le gouvernement y a tenu un langage de
fermeté pour réduire les dépenses
publiques avec un objectif clair
10 milliards d'euros d'économie d'ici la
fin du quinquennat et je salue cette
annonce
elle a le mérite de chlore pour de bons
l'air du quoi qu'il en coûte l'inflation
et la croissance devrait se tasser en
2023 la politique d'échec ne se justifie
donc plus
notre groupe soutient cette démarche
les dépenses et la dette publique n'ont
jamais été aussi élevées il devient donc
urgent de remettre de l'ordre dans nos
comptes
mais dans cette période anxiogène la
tâche s'annonce ardu sans Prée
aujourd'hui les débats budgétaires de
l'automne je veux revenir sur une
annonce faites lundi par la première
ministre le retour en septembre de la
loi de programmation de finances
publiques
cette loi de programmation avait été
adoptée au Sénat dans un esprit de
responsabilité et par solidarité avec
nos partenaires européens ce texte devra
préciser le cadre légal de réduction des
dépenses publiques il devra aussi
indiquer la contribution des
collectivités à cet effort partagé
monsieur le ministre les collectivités
font déjà des efforts conséquents vous
le savez et pour cause la règle d'or les
contraints à équilibrer leur budget les
collectivités ne représentent que 20%
des dépenses publiques et moins de 10%
de la dette autrement dit pour remettre
de l'ordre dans les comptes il ne serait
ni juste ni efficace de demander des
efforts supplémentaires aux
collectivités territoriales
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous donc
nous garantir que la loi de
programmation ne mettra pas les
collectivités à contribution
charger les comptes publics monsieur
Attal
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Emmanuel Capu effectivement
nous avons annoncé dans le cadre du
nouveau programme de stabilité que nous
avions décidé de revoir la charge de
l'effort et on l'a fait notamment à la
suite des échanges que nous avons eu au
Sénat et vous avez été vous-même
personnellement monsieur Capu une vigie
aussi sur ce sujet de l'effort des
collectivités locales en nous invitant
en nous invitant à avoir un effort plus
important en direction de l'État que
pour les collectivités locales je
rappelle que ce qui était prévu quand on
a présenté la loi de programmation des
finances publiques c'est une baisse de
0,4% des dépenses de l'État en volume et
de 0,5% pour les collectivités locales
et que dans la nouvelle loi de
programmation que nous vous présenterons
au mois de septembre dans les évolutions
que nous y introduirons nous prévoirons
désormais un effort bien plus important
pour l'État à -08%
je redis ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
en réponse à Madame apourceau poli on a
besoin les uns des autres on n'arrivera
pas à relever le défi de la transition
écologique si l'État et les
collectivités n'agissent pas de concerts
et pour agir de concerts il nous faut
garder le contrôle sur nos finances
publiques des endettés le pays moi je ne
pose pas les 3% et les trois degrés je
considère que si on veut être capable de
relever le défi de la transition
écologique il nous faut garder le
contrôle sur les finances publiques
remettre vraiment de l'ordre dans nos
comptes de manière à disposer des marges
de manœuvre budgétaire qui nous
permettront d'investir partout où c'est
nécessaire pour relever ce défi donc on
avancera ensemble Bruno Le Maire a
effectivement fait un certain nombre de
propositions à l'occasion des Assises il
a notamment proposé ce mécanisme
d'auto-assurance des collectivités
locales lorsqu'il y a un surcroît
exceptionnel de recettes de manière à ce
que ces fonds et ses moyens puissent
venir soutenir les collectivités locales
qui en ont besoin lorsque survient une
crise c'est une proposition qui est mise
dans le débat nous allons continuer à
avancer l'année dernière on a vu les
dialogues de Bercy pour construire le
budget nous allons rééditer l'opération
cette année en essayant de la faire
encore mieux c'est à dire avec davantage
de réunions davantage d'échanges pour
construire à la fois le budget 2024 mais
aussi la trajectoire et les moyens dont
état collectivité locale sécurité
sociale nous serons capables de rester
ces défis pour notre pays merci vous
avez quelques secondes monsieur Capu
merci monsieur le ministre vous le savez
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous êtes
élu local vous connaissez l'exaspération
des élus locaux ils sont prêts à faire
des efforts à condition qu'on diminue
les normes qu'on diminue le nombre de
contraintes et surtout qu'on leur laisse
l'autonomie financière dans leur
collectivité
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Gérard Lankais avant qu'il la
prenne
mais avant qu'il la prenne
je voudrais saluer Gérard Longuet qui a
pris la décision à la fin de nos
sessions de ne pas renouveler son mandat
il a été 22 ans dans cette émission il a
été président du groupe UMP et il a été
à la commission des finances j'allais
dire un orateur et quelqu'un qui a donné
toujours beaucoup d'élévation et je
voudrais saluer le travail qu'il a fait
comme président de l'Office
Parlementaire l'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques
bon ça c'était pas prévu
non non
oui oui merci monsieur le Président ce
n'était pas prévu
je souhaite simplement rester d'une
sérénité à toute épreuve car en effet
après 45 ans de mandat parlementaire le
jeune Gabriel Attal n'était pas né alors
que j'étais déjà député
c'est pour ça que je remercie de
répondre à cet instant avant Pierre
Bruno Le Maire a inauguré à installer
les premières Assises des finances
publiques comme écrivain je l'accepte
mais très honnêtement comme metteur en
scène il est nul
il s'est trompé
il y a un lieu pour les finances
publiques ça s'appelle le Parlement
c'est l'Assemblée nationale et c'est le
Sénat
une seule trompée ensuite il s'est
trompé ensuite parce qu'il y a pas une
première assise et on verra plus tard il
y a une urgence absolue pour redresser
les finances de notre pays et ma
question est d'une grande simplicité
même si mon excellent collègue a pu
semble la voir ouverte et bien je vais
enfoncer ma et le sujet est posé la
question suivante pourquoi diable
n'avez-vous pas
répondu à la commande de madame la
Première ministre c'est les abbé de
borne de présenter en elle s'était en
avril de présenter en juillet la loi de
programmation des finances publiques 23
monsieur Attal
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
ministre Gérard Longuet moi je réponds
toujours aux commandes de la première
ministre et j'ai entendu lundi une
commande de la première ministre a
présenté la loi de programmation des
finances publiques au mois de septembre
prochain et donc évidemment nous nous
mettons en ordre de marche avec Bruno Le
Maire pour la présenter en septembre
pourquoi est-ce qu'on la présente en
septembre je pense que c'était ça
derrière votre question parce que ça
davantage de sens de la présenter avec
le projet de loi de finances étant donné
des choix budgétaires majeurs que nous
allons devoir faire dans le cadre du PLF
pour qu'il soit intégré dans la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
plutôt que de représenter une loi de
programmation des finances publiques en
juillet et de devoir revenir ensuite en
septembre après la présentation du PLF
pour adapter le texte raison pour
laquelle nous reviendrons avec cette
programmation dont je rappelle qu'elle
avait été adoptée au Sénat avec un
quantum d'économie très important
supplémentaire qui avait été décidé par
votre assemblée je pense que ça sera
intéressant qu'on puisse avoir le débat
désormais sur ou est-ce que vous situez
ces économies supplémentaires et on
partagera chacun nos propositions et on
pourra échanger sur ce sujet là puisque
une fois avoir arbitré un quantum je
pense que c'est important d'être capable
de dire où est-ce que on identifie les
économies dans chaque périmètre
ministériel voilà évidemment monsieur le
sénateur monsieur le ministre je veux au
nom du gouvernement et à l'occasion de
cette dernière question au gouvernement
que vous prononcez ici vous rendre
hommage rendre hommage à votre parcours
c'est vrai que j'avais 12 ans je crois
quand vous êtes rentré ici au Sénat vous
avez eu l'occasion de le souligner mais
du coup je dois dire je me suis
intéressé très jeune à la vie politique
et donc j'ai l'impression de vous avoir
connu très jeune et d'avoir suivi votre
voix singulière dans le débat politique
en tant que ministre en tant que
parlementaire en tant président de
conseils régional aussi vous avez porté
une voie je crois importante dans le
débat politique et je suis absolument
convaincu que vous continuerez à porter
cette voie dans notre débat d'idées y
compris en dehors de cette assemblée je
vous remercie Monsieur Laurent
oui merci monsieur le Président je crois
avoir regardé un petit peu de temps pour
vous répondre et vous dire très
simplement que votre problème est un
problème de majorité politique soyez
très soyez rassurés vous n'êtes aucun
président de la République française
depuis l'élection au suffrage universel
n'a été élu à la majorité absolue au
premier tour tous ont eu à gérer des
majorités compliquées seul
sur les 14 élections législatives depuis
1967 seul à cette occasion 7 3 et 4 ont
le président obtenu une majorité à
travers son parti cela veut dire quoi
cela veut dire madame la Première
ministre qu'au cœur des institutions de
la Cinquième République il y a une
réalité parlementaire qui oblige le
président de la République a considéré
que ceux qui ont l'ont rallié au
deuxième tour mérite d'exister et d'être
prise en considération
effective
c'est exactement ce qui manque
aujourd'hui je ne parle pas conclure
alors je conclue très simplement vous
avez trois choix vous avez en effet la
coalition gouvernementale
c'est pas prévu et c'est pas dans le
caractère du Président vous avez la
cohabitation dans votre propre camp en
choisissant un premier ministre dont
vous pensez qu'il sera plus fédérateur
et vous avez enfin la dissolution je
regrette de ne pas être parlementaire
pour ces trois événements
la parole est à d'autres collègues
pierre fogier pour le groupe les
républicains
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
madame la Première ministre la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et dans l'attente
jour dans la tente mais désormais sa
longue histoire se poursuivra dans la
France
lors de son dernier voyage à Nouméa le
ministre de l'intérieur des Outre-mer a
engagé des échanges avec les différentes
forces politiques qui devraient aboutir
nous l'espérons à la co-construction
d'une solution d'avenir je tiens à lui
donner acte de sa détermination et alors
remercié pour ma part j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de vous le dire je me tiens à
vos dispositions enfin de vous
accompagner sur ce chemin
madame la Première ministre pour
parvenir à cette solution d'avenir nous
devons franchir un premier obstacle le
renouvellement des assemblées provinces
l'année prochaine et seul une réforme du
corps électoral pour ces élections les
rendra possible il vous appartient donc
au plus vite que nous proposer les voies
et les moyens pour y parvenir je veux
rappeler encore et encore qu'à la
signature de l'Accord de Nouméa le droit
de vote était acquis au terme du de Ré
une durée de résidence de 10 ans en
Nouvelle-Calédonie la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2007 qui nous a été
imposé y a mis un terme en fermant à
compter de 1998 l'accès au corps
électoral
mais surtout dans la première ministre
ces référendums successifs ont laissé
derrière eux une population profondément
divisée
pour tenter d'y remédier il nous faudra
porter une vision politique
susceptible de fédérer et de nourrir
cette communauté de destins à laquelle
nous aspirons une vision de façon à
permettre aux calédonien de se projeter
sur le long terme d'avoir l'ambition
d'un navire partagé et de ne pas se
laisser enfermer dans le sol des bas
institutionnels le contenu de cette
communauté de destin ce que l'on dénomme
la citoyenneté faites de droits et de
devoirs qui situera la place de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie dans la France son
identité particulière dans la solidarité
nationale madame la Première ministre ma
question est double
pouvez-vous vous engager sur un agenda
permettant la tenue des élections
provinciales avec un corps électoral
ouvert dès l'année prochaine
êtes-vous prêts nous accompagner pour
donner à la Nouvelle-Calédonie un
ensemble de règles qui définiront les
exigences de notre savoir-vivre ensemble
je vous remercie
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Pierre Frugier
le processus politique défini dans
l'Accord de Nouméa est arrivé à son
terme en décembre 2021 après trois
consultations référendaires successives
organisé sous l'autorité du Président de
la République
il appartient désormais aux partenaire
politique
d'examiner la situation ainsi créée
selon les termes même de la corde
vous le savez mon gouvernement est
pleinement mobilisé pour accompagner les
discussions sur l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie en moins d'un an le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outre-mer
et le ministre chargé des Outre-mer se
sont rendus sur place à quatre reprises
pour échanger avec l'ensemble des
acteurs calédoniens j'ai également réuni
une convention des partenaires à Paris
en octobre 2022 et rencontrer la
délégation du FLNKS et les représentants
non indépendantistes le 11 avril dernier
comme vous le savez les discussions
portent actuellement pour l'essentiel
sur les compétences sur l'exercice du
droit à l'autodétermination et sur
l'évolution du corps électoral
provincial
je l'affirme devant vous comme je l'ai
dit à la délégation du FLNKS je crois
qu'un gel indéfini du corps électoral
provincial questionnerait nos principes
démocratiques comme nos engagements
internationaux aujourd'hui les
discussions avancent et je mesure la
sensibilité de cette question le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
a fait des propositions sur une durée de
résidence minimale des échanges
techniques sont actuellement organisés
par le haut-commissaire à Nouméa et je
suis persuadé qu'une solution
consensuelle peut être trouvée sur ce
point comme sur les autres je suis prête
à inviter l'ensemble des partenaires à
partir de la fin du mois d'août pour
conclure l'accord que les Calédoniens
attendent quant aux élections
provinciales elles auront lieu en tout
état de cause en 2024 c'est un enjeu
démocratique
monsieur le sénateur l'esprit de
l'Accord de Nouméa qui doit nous
inspirer et que vous incarnez en tant
que signataire en 1998 n'est pas
seulement un mécanisme institutionnel et
juridique c'est avant tout l'ambition
profondément humaine du destin commun je
crois que cette ambition répond à
l'attente de nombreux jeunes calédoniens
alors soyons collectivement à la hauteur
des signatures des signataires des
accords de 1988 et 1998
et peut-être si vous le permettez
monsieur le Président je voudrais
terminer cette réponse en rendant
hommage à mon tour à monsieur le
président Gérard Longuet ancien ministre
et président de groupe mais aussi au
président Jean-Pierre Sueur ancien
ministre ancien président de la
commission des lois et questeur de votre
assemblée et à la sénatrice Michel
meunier qui siège dans ses travées qui
siège dans ses travées depuis 12 ans
vous êtes ici des voies qui portent
respectées pour votre connaissance fine
des dossiers et votre volonté devrait
pour les Français nous avons pu nous
opposer mais nous avons toujours su
travailler ensemble au service de la
République et de l'intérêt général je
vous remercie
alors je vais donner immédiatement la
parole à Jean-Pierre sfeur qui lui aussi
22 années au Sénat et je dois dire
sans doute un chiffre record de
nombreuxeurs passées dans les fauteuils
de l'hémicycle nous allons publier ces
œuvres complètes merci très bien tôt et
comme président de la commission des
lois
président de la commission des lois mais
oui comme question du Sénat
merci monsieur le Président c'est trop
je voulais juste vous interroger madame
la Première ministre sur ce qui s'est
passé dans la nuit du 13 mai au large de
la Grèce et qui est une honte pour notre
civilisation
750 hommes femmes enfants
entassés comme des bêtes
dans un bateau qui a péri on naufragé et
nous savons aujourd'hui que fontex qu'un
certain nombre d'États que des
garde-côtes savaient
que c'était un péril imminent
les images de la BBC ont montré que
pendant 7 heures ce bateau était là
entre la vie et la mort est plus près de
la mort alors nous ne pouvons pas nous
résigner
à ce qu'il y ait 500 60700 morts qui
viennent s'ajouter aux 10000 des 4 ou 5
dernières années au 20 000 ou 30 000
nous ne savons pas ceux de la Manche et
je demande simplement madame la Première
ministre que la France pèse de tout son
poids
pour qu'il y ait vraiment une politique
pour mettre fin au naufrage de ces êtres
humains
pour vous répondre la parole
est à
charger des partenariats internationaux
vous avez la parole
mais si elle est Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs
souvenirs les 14 juin au large de la
Grèce et avant tout comme vous avez dit
un drame au Mans un des plus souvenir
Méditerranée et vous avez totalement
raison oui nous ne pouvons pas se
résigner
cette tragédie nous bouleverse tous et
je voulais renouveler nos condoléances
aux familles des victimes
et bien sûr elle nous oblige
car nous devons tout mettre en oeuvre
pour éviter de nouveau drame de ce type
et notamment au niveau européen
l'accord trouvé le 8 juin par les
ministres européen de l'Intérieur
permettra d'y apporter une réponse et
européenne sur ces sujets à la question
du traitement de demande d'asile une
réponse qui doit lier responsabilité
efficacité et solidarité la France et
l'Italie sont pleinement mobilisés à ses
sens comme le soulignait hier le
président de la République et la
première ministre Georgia Meloni
mais ces drames rappelle aussi
l'importance de la coopération avec les
pays tiers en matière de sauvetage en
mer et des luttes contre les réseaux de
passeurs là encore les travaux sont en
cours au niveau européen en particulier
avec la Tunisie notre objectif est de
renforcer les capacités
pour mieux lutter contre ceux qui
exploitent la détresse des migrants
contre les causes profondes de l'air
exil enfin Monsieur le Kester comme
aujourd'hui c'est votre dernier question
le gouvernement et ce soit je souhaite
aussi profiter pour vous saluer attendez
député ministre sénateur président de la
commission des lois maire de Orléans
vous nous avez marqué pendant 40 ans par
vos convictions
et votre engagement permanent la
République les Sénat et votre serre
Loiret vous ne sont reconnaissants
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
Président puisqu'il me reste ce quelques
secondes je voulais dire simplement que
par rapport aux étrangers mes chers
collègues par rapport aux immigrés
il est facile
d'exploiter constamment ce sujet alors
que nous ne devons pas l'exploiter faire
de la politique politicienne facile avec
les étrangers en disant que les
étrangers sont un danger pour notre pays
mes chers collègues il y a des problèmes
qu'il faut traiter et qu'il ne faut pas
exploiter surtout lorsqu'il y a des
centaines et des milliers de personnes
qui dans la mer Méditerranée sont en
danger merci pour ce que vous ferez tous
pour bien prendre conscience qu'il nous
faut une politique énergie
impulsée par la France au niveau de
l'Europe pour sauver ses êtres humains
[Applaudissements]
au président Jean-François Rapin pour le
groupe les républicains
monsieur le président madame la ministre
je partage ce propos avec ma collègue la
présidente Sophie prima en octobre 2019
la première ministre déclarait qu'on ne
peut pas signer un accord commercial
avec un pays qui ne respecte pas la
forêt amazonienne qui ne respecte pas le
traité de Paris la France ne signera pas
l'accord avec le Mercosur dans ses
conditions plus récemment lors de sa
visite au salon de l'agriculture le 25
février dernier le président Emmanuel
Macron expliqué qu'un accord avec les
pays du continent latino-américain n'est
pas possible s'il ne respecte pas comme
nous les accords de Paris ni les mêmes
contraintes environnementales et
sanitaires qu'on impose à nos
producteurs mais il y a 15 jours Olivier
bèche avait déclaré qu'il fallait
conclure cet accord avec le Mercosur qui
est en négociation depuis 23 ans la
semaine dernière la présidente de la
Commission européenne
Ursula vanderleyen à elle aussi espérer
publiquement lors de sa tournée en
Amérique latine que l'Union européenne
conclue d'ici la fin de l'année cet
accord
qui prend dans 10 jours la présidence du
Conseil de l'Union européenne sera aussi
très allante bref la barque prend l'eau
de toutes parts et nous sommes très
inquiets d'autant plus que la Commission
européenne est en mesure de tenir à
l'écart les parlements nationaux de la
ratification de l'accord en décembre
dernier notre collègue à l'encadet bien
au fait de ce danger vous avez déjà
interrogé la question se fait plus
pressante encore aujourd'hui madame la
ministre le président Macron risque-t-il
de trahir vendredi sa parole envers le
monde agricole lorsqu'il se recevra à
Paris monsieur Lula redevenu président
du Brésil
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à la secrétaire d'État
chargé des partenariats internationaux
vous avez la parole
mais si elle est président mesdames
messieurs les sénateur mais si elle est
président Jean-François rapan
je vous prie tout d'abord d'excuser la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères actuellement déplacement la
France comme nombre de pays européens
exprimaient ses préoccupations sur
l'accord Union européenne mercure dès
2019 notamment pour des raisons
environnementales la Commission
européenne a fait des efforts notamment
sur la question de la déforestation mais
cela reste insuffisant
des négociations sont en courant pour
apporter des réponses supplémentaires la
France a refermé trois conditions et
indispensables pour nous engager sur cet
accord les premiers comme vous avez
souligné l'accord de Paris comme élément
essentiels
développement durable de l'accord avec
la nouvelle approche de la commission
c'est-à-dire avec nos meilleurs
standards en matière environnementale et
sociale et en parallèle de l'accord un
programme ambitieux sous les mesures
miroirs vu les enjeux de cet accord nous
nous opposons à sa scission nous
souhaitons qu'il soit présenté au
Parlement nationaux les présidents de la
République et le président brésilienne
auront l'occasion comme vous avez dit
d'échanger sur ces sujets comme sur la
table des enjeux bilatéraux et globaux
en mars du sommet pour un nouveau pack
financier organisé ces deux prochaines
jours je vous remercie
monsieur le président
madame la ministre nous prenons acte
aujourd'hui de vos paroles en disant que
vous n'excluez pas le Parlement
nationaux de cette discussion et c'est
essentiel rappelez les trois clauses que
la France exige et c'est à VOUS
gouvernement au conseil de défendre les
agriculteurs français et la France en
tout cas la commission des affaires
européennes que je peux que je préside y
veillera
merci
la parole est à notre collègue je suis
une guidez pour le groupe du l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse au ministre de la
santé et de la prévention et porte sur
l'un des indicateurs clés pour évaluer
la santé d'une population cela fait 7
ans que la mortalité infantile en France
est supérieure à la moyenne européenne
alors qu'elle était l'une des plus
basses de robes à la fin du 20e siècle
alors que la France figuré parmi les
meilleurs élèves en troisième position
le pays a chuté en 20e place sur 27 en
2021 2700 nourrisson de moins d'un an
ont perdu la vie en France soit 3,7
décès pour 1000 naissances vivantes
j'appelle ce que particulièrement votre
attention sur l'évolution préoccupante
de certains indicateurs de santé
périnatale dans trois régions
métropolitaines l'Île-de-France le
centre Val de Loire et le Grand Est mais
aussi dans les départements ultramarins
le taux de mortalité infantile est de
8,9% à Mayotte 8,2% en Guyane et 8,1% en
Guadeloupe alors qu'il s'établit à 3,5
en France hexagonale
la Cour des comptes dans son rapport
pour sur la santé dans les outre-mer en
2012 mettez déjà en lumière le manque de
pédiatre et de gynécologue monsieur le
ministre quelles sont les explications
possibles à cette tendance
spécifiquement française quels sont les
mesures de prévention prises ou
envisagées par le gouvernement pour
endiguer cette surmortalité infantile en
outre-mer ainsi dans les quatre
départements de la France métropolitaine
à savoir la Seine-Saint-Denis le Jura
l'Indre-et-Loire et le lot je vous
remercie
merci pour vos réponses la parole est
communiste de la santé de la prévention
Monsieur François borne
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice guidez la lutte contre la
mortalité infantile est effectivement un
enjeu majeur c'est l'un des marqueurs de
l'état de notre système de santé grâce
au projet de la médecine ou politique de
santé ciblée le taux de mortalité
infantile est aujourd'hui historiquement
bas il faut s'en souvenir l'Insee le dit
d'ailleurs il est particulièrement bas
dans notre histoire néanmoins ce n'est
pas un acquis il faut continuer à
progresser il faut continuer à rester
mobilisé en effet cette étude montre
aussi et vous l'avez dit que ce taux ne
baisse plus à même légèrement augmenté
ces dernières années notamment dans la
première existence première semaine
d'existence de l'enfant
la santé des enfants ça commence dès les
premiers jours dès les premières heures
c'est pour cela que nous avons rendu la
vaccination du nourrisson obligatoire à
ce titre je m'assure je contre les
discours qui continuent à relativiser
voire dénigrer l'importance de la
vaccination
nous avons élargi le test systématique
de dépistage néonatal qui permet
désormais de détecter et de prendre en
charge 13 maladies graves de l'enfant
nous avons aussi déployé une stratégie
sur les 1000 premiers jours de l'enfant
pour associer parents professionnels de
santé autour de la santé physique de la
santé mentale de l'enfant bien entendu
le travail ne s'arrête pas là travailler
tous les aspects de la santé de
l'enfance c'est l'état d'esprit dans
lequel j'ai installé des Assises de la
santé de l'enfant et de la pédiatrie les
différents groupes de travail sont à
l'oeuvre depuis plusieurs mois leur
conclusion est propositions nous serons
rendus très prochainement avec un
ciblage très particulier sur la
situation de nos outre-mer
par exemple nous avons déjà pu avancer
dans le cadre de leurs travaux sur la
profession et la rénovation du métier
d'infirmière puéricultrice pour adapter
la formation et leur exercice aux
nouveaux enjeux de la prise en charge de
l'enfant
sur les maternités puisque le sujet est
souvent mis en parallèle loin de toute
gestion purement comptable d'un autre
temps je veux créer un nouveau modèle
qui allie non seulement le suivi
périnatal avant et après la naissance en
proximité le plus possible mais qui
sécurise surtout l'acte d'accouchement
sur des plateaux techniques ou toutes
les compétences sont rassemblées je vous
remercie
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez raison il faut sortir
certaines lampadaire les vaccinations
le taux de mentalité infantile ne baisse
plus depuis 20 ans 20 années et on est
en 20e place sur 27 en Europe mais c'est
catastrophique je suis très donc cette
phrase de Mac bloc dans l'étrange des
fêtes français je vais être contraint
parlant de mon pays de ne pas s'en
parler qu'en bien il est dur de devoir
découvrir les faiblesses d'une mère
douloureuse voilà j'espère que vous
allez pouvoir en tous les cas avancer
sur ce sujet parce que moi je ne reviens
pas de la place que nous avons alors
nous sommes en France merci beaucoup
merci
donner la parole à notre collègue
Jean-Baptiste pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues cette question s'adressait au
ministre de l'économie et des finances
j'ai associé mes collègues loisiers
Martin et Reitmans un hectare de forêt
qui brûle c'est un moyen de 46 tonnes de
CO2 qui sont libérés en 2022 72000
hectares ont libéré 3 milliards et demi
de tonnes de carbone la proposition de
loi d'initiative sénatoriale visant à
renforcer la prévention et la lutte
contre l'intensification et l'extension
du risque incendie a fait l'objet d'un
accord en commission mixte paritaire
cependant les députés sous la pression
comptable de Bercy ont refusé d'accorder
aux collectivités territoriales le
bénéfice de la réduction de cotisations
patronales en contrepartie de la mise à
disposition d'employés sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires pour les services d'incendie
et de secours outre qu'une telle mesure
aurait pu alléger une longue charge
financière les collectivités et plus
particulièrement les plus petites la
sécurité civile se trouvera en pratique
privée d'un vivier de recrutement
important de sapeurs-pompiers volontaire
dans un contexte pourtant marqué par une
crise aiguë d'évocation autre regret le
renoncement des députés à une mesure
forte en faveur de la protection massive
de la forêt par le débroussaillement
reconnu par les 10 comme moyen de
limiter la propagation du feu où tout au
moins afin que la forêt soit plus
aisément défendable l'étude sur la
valeur du Sauvet parle d'elle-même un
euro investi dans la prévention contre
les feux de forêt permet d'éviter 20 à
25 euros de dépenses quand elle est en
feu lorsqu'on envisage de dépenser des
milliards pour décarboner notre économie
vous refusez de dépenser 4 millions pour
aider les collectivités à mieux défendre
la forêt et d'accompagner les
particuliers à engager leur première
opérations de débroussaillement quel
paradoxe le texte issu de la CMP manque
d'ambition sur son volet financier au
nom des considérations budgétaires de
court terme et je le regrette
monsieur le ministre il ne faut pas
penser à la forêt que lorsqu'elle brûle
quand l'État va-t-il prendre ses
responsabilités pour qu'en dépit du
changement climatique la forêt continue
à jouer son rôle depuis le carbone
pour vous répondre la parole comme
Madame sodia Bacquet secrétaire d'État
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Baki je voudrais d'abord vous
remercier pour la proposition de loi que
vous portez avec Anne-Catherine Loisier
Pascal Martin et Olivier rethmann qui
vient de faire l'objet d'une CMP
conclusive à l'issue de la procédure
accélérée votre produit proposition
apporte de nombreuses avancées dans
l'appréhension de la protection de nos
forêts avec l'élaboration d'une
stratégie nationale et
interministérielle de défense vous créez
un continuum de prise en compte de ce
risque depuis la prévention jusqu'aux
actions de reboisement et de
reconstitution de forêt plus résiliante
le travail que vous avez mené a fait
l'objet d'un large consensus les
échanges avec l'ensemble des partenaires
et acteurs ont été très nombreux et je
m'en félicite tous reconnaissent la
qualité des travaux comme les très
grandes avancées que vous avez proposées
concernant la mesure relative à
l'exonération de charges sociales pour
les employeurs vous avez fait le choix
d'une expérimentation pendant trois ans
ce dispositif est inédit il va permettre
à nos concitoyens qui s'investissent
pour le bien public d'être encore plus
disponible pour mener des actions de
secours
le choix a été fait dès le début de ne
pas intégrer les collectivités
territoriales en tant que bénéficiaire
il existe vous le savez d'autres
mécanismes qui les concernent
directement comme la possibilité de
diminuer leur contribution obligatoire
au service d'incendiés de secours si
elles mettent à disposition leurs agents
nous n'avons pas retenu non plus la mise
en place du crédit d'impôt sur les
obligations légales de débroussaillement
parce qu'il s'agit si il s'agissait ici
pardon de mettre les bonnes dépenses au
bon endroit et cette loi n'était pas le
vecteur le plus opportun cela n'enlève
en rien la qualité de cette loi une loi
consensuelle qui va mieux nous armer
pour faire face à ce défi du changement
climatique le gouvernement adresse un
message de soutien à l'ensemble des
acteurs au premier rang desquels les
sapeurs-pompiers qui vont dans les jours
à venir de voir lutter activement contre
les feux vous pourrez toujours compter
sur notre soutien je vous remercie merci
je vais céder la parole de notre
collègue Michel meunier
elle aussi c'est une de ces dernières
interventions
dans notre hémicycle je voudrais moi
aussi saluer son travail bien sûr à la
commission des affaires sociales nous
avons toutes en tête le rapport qu'elle
a fait sur bien vieillir avec Bernard
bonne il y a peu de temps je voudrais
salué devant les collègues la
vice-présidente du comité de déontologie
parlementaire remarquable qu'elle a été
avec Arnaud bazar
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
c'est avec gravité que je pose ma
question au ministre de la Santé de la
prévention monsieur le ministre
l'insistance de votre gouvernement a
ignorer les alertes des professionnels
du soin à détricoter notre modèle social
à opposer les Français précaires aux
Français méritants plonge un bon nombre
d'entre eux dans une détresse physique
et mentale insupportable l'état de santé
de notre pays se dégrade les dépenses de
santé augmentent c'est normal les
dépenses de santé augmentent et vous
faites la chasse aux arrêts maladie et
diminuer le remboursement des soins
dentaires c'est normal non ça c'est
grave grave car les dépenses dentaires
réglées par les complémentaires seront
répercutés sur les cotisations des
mutuelles elle diminueront ainsi le
pouvoir d'achat des assurés
pas grave car les accidents du travail
touchent plus fortement le secteur du
soin ou de l'aide à domicile en raison
précisément de leur tension de
recrutement voilà le système de soins de
demain si vous ne réagissez pas monsieur
le ministre une santé à deux vitesses
des soins pour les plus aisés et leur
complémentaires Premium et des
renoncements aux soins pour les plus
précaires coincés dans la file des
urgences attendant d'être soignée par
d'autres précaires ma question est
simple allez vous changer de logique et
enfin investir dans le système de soins
et le recrutement des soignantes et des
soignants plutôt de que de conforter ce
cercle vicieux d'austérité sanitaire
[Applaudissements]
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
monsieur Braun
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Michel meunier merci de me
réserver votre dernière question dans
cette dans cette émission cela me permet
de saluer votre carrière au service de
nos concitoyens et également votre
question va me permettre de rétablir
quelques vérités
nous sommes le gouvernement la majorité
qui inventait le 100% santé sur
l'optique les prothèses auditives le
dentaire c'est un progrès majeur en
matière d'accès à la santé pour nos
concitoyens ceci n'est bien sûr pas
remis en cause ceci dément le principe
la volonté que nous pourriez avoir de
faire une médecine à deux vitesses loin
de là ce progrès nous l'avons construit
avec des complémentaires santé
absolument pas en opposition avec elle
bien au contraire et depuis que je suis
arrivé au ministère je les rencontre
très régulièrement
depuis 2011 en raison de la progression
des affections de longue durée dans
notre pays mais aussi des nombreuses
dépenses prises en compte par 100% par
l'Assurance Maladie la sécurité sociale
assume une part de plus en plus
importante des dépenses par rapport aux
complémentaires
son intervention de la sécurité sociale
lors des prises en charge à augmenter de
3 points pendant que celle des
complémentaires diminuaient de 1 point
est celle des ménages de deux points
aujourd'hui nous devons garantir
l'avenir de notre système de santé
l'accès à tous aux innovations pour
faire face aux nouveaux enjeux comme par
exemple comme le virage préventif dans
ce cadre tous les acteurs doivent faire
des efforts y compris les
complémentaires c'est le sens de la
mesure à laquelle vous faites référence
qui prévoit un plus grand engagement
financier des complémentaires dans les
soins dentaires afin de mettre en place
aux côtés de l'Assurance Maladie un 100%
prévention réussir l'objectif d'une
génération sans carie
s'agissant des arrêts maladie oui nous
examinons soigneusement la situation
bien sûr afin d'en limiter les abus ou
qu'ils soient je serai bien sûr très
vigilant au sein de ce gouvernement à ce
que les Français se voient indemniser à
juste proportion lorsqu'ils sont malades
vous le voyez madame la sénatrice ce
gouvernement a une ligne claire oui il
est légitime d'identifier des marges
d'économie là où cela est possible et
supportable pour garantir la pérennité
de nos systèmes de protection mais cela
ne se fera jamais au détriment de
l'accès aux soins pour tous les Français
je vous remercie madame meunier monsieur
le ministre nous ne serons pas d'accord
vous sapez l'hôpital public vous
ne répondez pas à nos propositions par
exemple de mettre un ratio de soignants
par patient et vous ne répondez pas non
plus à la colère de celle et ceux qui
cotisent et qui voit le nombre de
soignants diminués et qui surtout ne
voient pas le fruit de leur effort
[Musique]
de notre collègue elles achèvent pour le
groupe les républicains
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Intérieur et j'y associe mes collègues
du Bas-Rhin l'occupation illégale de
terrain par les gens du voyage est une
problématique qui revient régulièrement
sans coquin changement ne soit constaté
jusqu'à quand cette situation va-t-elle
durer les collectivités se sont pourtant
mises en conformité avec la loi des
aires de grand passage ont été mises en
place des coûts conséquents ont été
engagés mais le problème reste entier
monsieur le ministre il est urgent
d'entendre le profond sentiment
d'abandon et de découragement des mères
confrontés à cette situation comment
concevoir qu'un élu local se retrouve un
dimanche soir en première ligne à devoir
gérer l'arrivée imprévue de plusieurs
centaines de caravanes sans parler de
l'incompréhension et de la colère
exprimée par la population les mères
après s'être mis en conformité avec les
départementaux s'attendait à être
soutenu et accompagné pour faire face
aux difficultés le résultat est tout
autre il se sent seul et ne peuvent
malheureusement que constater
l'affaiblissement de l'autorité de
l'État pour eux c'est la double peine
celle de payer et de continuer à subir
un exemple en Alsace ou une collectivité
est confrontée à l'arrivée de 44
caravanes elle a investi 700000 euros
pour créer une aire de passage à l'heure
actuelle l'air est totalement déserte
les gens du voyage refusant de s'y
installer lui préférant un terrain de
football à cela il faut ajouter des
incivilités des dégradations commis sur
les branchements et les compteurs d'eau
monsieur le ministre cette situation
n'est tout simplement plus tenable il
est temps que ces agissements illégaux
s'arrêtent et que le non-respect de la
loi soit sanctionné il est urgent
d'adapter les lois bessons mais
également de renforcer le travail de
coordination en amont monsieur le
ministre les élus locaux ont pris leur
responsabilité en créant des airs le
Sénat a pris les siennes en votant
notamment le texte de notre collègue
Patrick chaise pour faciliter la
procédure d'évacuation et durcir les
sanctions quand allez-vous enfin prendre
les vôtres
pour vous répondre
le ministre délégué Jean-François caraco
c'est le président madame la sénatrice
Chalte le sujet des installations
illicite est en effet un sujet fort et
milieu intérieur d'outre-mer que je
représente aujourd'hui est pleinement
mobilisé d'abord il nous fallait mieux
réprimer c'est le sens de la voile de
2018 qui a soupli les conditions
permettant de saisir le pressé pour
mettre en demeure les gens du voyage de
quitter les terrains occupés les
sitesment avec emploi de la force si
nécessaire elle a également renforcé les
sections les sanctions pénales pour ce
délit de six mois d'emprisonnement et
3750 euros d'amende à un an
d'emprisonnement et 7500 euros d'angle
ça a été durci fortement mais le sujet
des installations illicites est aussi
lié aux conditions d'accueil sur
lesquelles nous devons collectivement
travailler ainsi l'ensemble des préfets
est immobilisé en janvier 2022 afin de
relancer les schémas départementaux
d'accueil d'habitat des gens du voyage
le bilan réalisé montre je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous montrez que des
efforts demeurent à fournir en la
matière
par ailleurs je rappelle pour la
coordination d'un référent ministériel
gens du voyage a été nommé celui-ci
chargé d'entretenir les relations avec
les élus et les organisations
représentatives et d'intervenir sur les
difficultés signalées enfin une
circulaire a été prise de 24 avril 2023
c'est assez récent adressé au préfet sur
la gestion des grands passages estivaux
un courrier est un voyage l'ensemble des
responsables d'associations des gens du
voyage afin de le rappeler les grands
principes informations préalable
répartition des demandes dans le enne
dans l'espace
vigilance qu'un vigilance quant à
l'intégrité la propreté des équipements
l'intention du gouvernement est bien
d'avancée sur les deux aspects offrir
les conditions d'un meilleur accueil et
réprimer plus efficacement les
installations illicites la vie est ainsi
faite que j'ai jamais simple
la parole est à notre collègue Sabine
Rexel pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
trop souvent perçu comme une charge le
patrimoine marque une culture une
identité il permet également de créer de
l'activité et de l'emploi le petit
patrimoine ne fait l'objet d'aucune
protection à moins que celle-ci ne soit
spécifiée dans les documents d'urbanisme
ce patrimoine ce sont des lavoirs des
fours à pains des calvaires mais aussi
des maisons à colombages en Alsace ou
des malumières en Bretagne ce sont les
maisons vigneronnes d'Occitanie et les
burons du Cantal les échoppes
bordelaises et les longères de Vendée ou
encore Les Chalets Du Briançonnet les
meulière d'Île-de-France toutes comme
encore les chaumières normandes les
maisons basses ou les mas de Provence
caractérise nos régions et font
l'attractivité de notre pays
par définition se bâtit vers maculaire
et durable d'abord par sa longévité mais
aussi par sa soutenabilité car il a été
construit en fonction du climat et des
ressources locales et grâce aux qualités
que celle-ci lui confère il contribue
naturellement à une réduction
conséquente de l'utilisation du
chauffage et de la climatisation
aujourd'hui le DPE devenu opposable et
l'urgence de la décarbonation amène de
nombreux propriétaires de ce type de
bien à réaliser des travaux d'isolation
inadaptés mais subventionné et sans le
savoir il porte des atteintes parfois
fatales d'autres délaissent leur bien
qui finira dégrader puis vendu pour
s'enfoncier les ABS nous disent qu'ils
ne parviennent plus aujourd'hui à
endiguer la vague d'isolation par
l'extérieur y compris dans les secteurs
protégés
monsieur le ministre que comptez-vous
mettre en oeuvre pour empêcher que des
gestes ou des matériaux inappropriés ne
viennent porter des atteintes
définitives au bâti patrimonial de notre
pays
monsieur Béchu ministre de la cohésion
des territoires vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice drifler j'aimerais associer si
vous m'autorisez le président Lafont à
la question que vous venez de me poser
il y a quelques mois vous êtes venus me
voir tous les deux pour insister sur le
risque qu'il y aurait avoir une vision
aveugle et uniforme des règles du DPE au
mépris de la résistance je vais utiliser
un mot qu'on utilisait pas à l'époque
mais de la résilience d'une partie de
ces maisons de pleine pierre et des
types d'habitats qui sont construits il
y a quelques jours au début du mois de
juin la ministre de la Culture est
moi-même compte tenu du lien
hiérarchique que nous avons avec les ABS
avons reçu le cri d'alarme d'une dizaine
d'associations patrimoniales qui a
relayé une partie des propositions qui
avait été faites par votre commission je
veux aussi dire à quel point ce sujet
nous le prenons au sérieux ce que nous
avons demandé aux ABS c'est de nous
aider à montrer ce qui était possible
c'est le cas quand à l'hôtel de roclor
que j'occupe de manière temporaire
nous sommes en train d'explorer la
géothermie pour éviter pour trouver un
moyen de décarbonation qui ne touche ni
au façade ni à l'apparence du bâtiment
c'est le cas quand partout on se demande
ce qui est possible et non pas comment
on cherche l'excuse pour ne pas faire je
le dis d'autant plus volontiers que
c'est une part de notre identité de
notre âme vous avez cité les longères de
Vendée il m'aurait évidemment plus que
vous puissiez jusqu'au troglodyte du
saumuroir ou jusqu'à une partie des
clochettes hors du Haut-Anjou mais c'est
l'occasion pour moi de dire qu'il y a
sur nos territoires ce sera pour moi
l'occasion de saluer le président
retaillau des collectivités je dis très
sérieusement qui ont pris à bras le
corps la question du petit patrimoine en
mesurant que c'était à la fois un moyen
d'aller soutenir nos ruralité c'est ce
que la première ministre a mis à
l'honneur il y a quelques jours au
travers du plan France ruralité qui va
nous permettre de mieux accompagner
l'ensemble des territoires de préserver
une partie de nos cultures et de se
préoccuper de ce qui nous permet de
préparer l'avenir en nous appuyant sur
le passé il faut une forme de transition
mais en l'adaptant la réalité de ce
patrimoine c'est une nécessité pas
seulement de mémoire mais aussi de
cohésion
merci merci madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres je
vous rappelle que nos prochaines
questions d'actualité auront lieu de
mercredi 28 juin à 15h je vais suspendre
la séance et elle sera reprise à 16h30
pour l'examen de la promotion de loi
visant à lutter contre le dumping social
sur le transmanche la séance est
suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement du Sénat que
vous avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur notre antenne parmi les
temps forts cette semaine on a noté ces
hommages au sénateur sénatrice qui vont
quitter le Sénat cet été vous le savez
le 24 septembre prochain lors des
prochaines élections sénatoriales c'est
la moitié de la chambre haute qui va
être renouvelée plusieurs sénateurs ne
se représentent pas et donc à l'approche
de la fin de la session parlementaire le
président du Sénat a tenu à leur rendre
hommage on parle par exemple du LR
Gérard Longuet et dessinateur PS
jean-Pierre Sueur et la sénatrice Michel
meunier alors par exemple Gérard Longuet
il a été député de 1978 à 993 puis et
bien sénateur depuis 2001 plusieurs fois
ministre par exemple ministre de la
Défense sous Nicolas Sarkozy il a été
président du groupe
UMP à la fin des années 2000 au Sénat et
il a profité de cette séance pour donner
un petit conseil politique à l'exécutif
écouter
vous avez trois choix vous avez en effet
la coalition gouvernementale
c'est pas prévu et c'est pas dans le
caractère du Président vous avez la
cohabitation dans votre propre camp en
choisissant un premier ministre dont
vous pensez qu'il sera plus fédérateur
et vous avez enfin la dissolution je
regrette de ne pas être parlementaire
pour ces trois événements
l'exécutif également qui n'a pas répondu
directement à ce conseil mais Gabriel
Attal le jeune ministre a juste remarqué
qu'il avait 12 ans lorsque Gérard
Longuet était devenu sénateur pour la
première fois les deux personnalités
socialistes qui quittent le Sénat
Jean-Pierre Sueur il avait été élu
député trois fois puis il était et bien
élu pour la troisième fois cette fois-ci
sénateur il était entré dans la lumière
lors de et bien la commission d'enquête
Benalla dont il était rapporteur enfin
Michel meunier était une membre
importante de la commission d'affaires
sociale et notamment aussi de la
délégation au droit des femmes plus tard
dans cette séance on a entendu la
première ministre qu'il aura rendu
également hommage à ces trois sénateurs
sénatrices qui ne se représentent pas
écouter
et peut-être si vous le permettez
monsieur le Président je voudrais
terminer cette réponse en rendant
hommage à mon tour à monsieur le
président Gérard Longuet ancien ministre
et président de groupe mais aussi au
président Jean-Pierre Sueur ancien
ministre ancien président de la
commission des lois et questeur de votre
assemblée et à la sénatrice Michel
meunier qui siège dans ses travées qui
siège dans ses travées depuis 12 ans
vous êtes ici des voies qui portent
respectées pour votre connaissance fine
des dossiers et votre volonté devrait
pour les Français nous avons pu nous
opposer mais nous avons toujours su
travailler ensemble au service de la
République et de l'intérêt général je
vous remercie voilà Gérard Longuet
jean-Pierre Sueur Michel meunier des
personnalités importantes bien connues
de la rédaction publique Sénat aussi à
Montpellier des experts sur leur sujet
et des témoins aussi de la vie politique
que nous sollicitons régulièrement sur
cette antenne une page va se tourner
aussi allez elle de tourner mais pour
l'instant et bien Jean-Pierre soirée est
toujours membre du Sénat et il est au
micro d'Alexandre poussin voilà c'est
l'une des personnalités qui a été saluée
aujourd'hui et que publique c'est la
salut également aujourd'hui et qui a
posé une question lors des questions
gouvernement Alexandre effectivement
Jean-Pierre vous allez quitter le Sénat
après 22 ans de mandat quel est votre
sentiment à ce moment-là j'ai le
vraiment le sentiment d'un devoir
accompli c'est vrai que j'aurais aimé
peut-être rester mais la sagesse vous
savez m'a conduit a décidé dès 2017
qu'il fallait passer le relais vous
voyez j'ai 76 ans bon j'ai 42 ans
demandait à électif député maire mini
sénateur mon derrière moi et ça a été
une passion je dois vous dire que le
fait de travailler sur toutes ces lois
de contrôler le gouvernement et puis
toutes les semaines d'aller dans mon
département de revenir d'essayer de
porter ici ce que j'entends là-bas c'est
une vie absolument passionnante et je
remercierai toujours les électeurs du
Loiret les élus du Loiret de
bondépartement de m'avoir offert cette
chance dont je ne suis pas du tout
triste parce que la vie continue et vous
retenez de votre passage au Sénat au
l'ensemble peut-être la question de
l'affaire Benalla parce que d'être
rapporteur d'une d'une commission
d'enquête qui a eu un tel retentissement
et qui a vous savez trois ans après pas
une ligne de notre rapport on a passé
des jours et des nuits n'a été contestée
et ça c'est aussi très important de dire
qu'on a besoin que le Parlement exerce
sa mission de contrôle surtout quand il
y a un dysfonctionnement plus haut
niveau de la République mais si vous
encore une fois j'ai tenu à dire
tout à l'heure en réponse à la réplique
du goût à la réponse du gouvernement
s'agissant des étrangers qu'il était
tellement facile de utiliser les
étrangers de dire qu'ils sont un danger
pour faire de la politique politicienne
aujourd'hui quand on regarde le naufrage
qui s'est produit en Grèce ce sont des
étrangers qui sont en danger et nous
devons tout faire pour que ça ne se
renouvelle pas pour sauver ces êtres
humains et en finira sur ces mots merci
beaucoup
à notre micro pour votre dernière
question d'actualité au Gouvernement
merci beaucoup merci merci beaucoup
Alexandrie vous l'avez dit il y a eu
bien plusieurs hommages qui ont été
rendus à des personnalités politiques
qui vont donc quitter le Sénat au mois
de septembre et l'une de ces autres
personnalités politiques on l'a entendu
également c'est Gérard Longuet et il est
à votre micro Alexandre bonjour
alors vous allez quitter le Sénat après
[Musique]
mais pour approfondir les les secteurs
d'activité sur lesquels on a un peu
d'expérience de compétences donc selon
vous le bilan d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
d'avoir un petit peu diminuer la qualité
du débat politique en France c'est pas
de son fait mais nous avons des
institutions à l'origine voulue par
général de Gaulle et par Michel Debré
qui sont des institutions parlementaires
et petit à petit et c'est ce que j'ai
voulu dire le Parlement donne le
sentiment d'être contourné par un
président qui parle directement à
l'opinion française et d'ailleurs le
vigno français ne s'y trompe pas qui
s'adresse par les sondages directement
au président et on court-circuite de
fait
les institutions que sont l'Assemblée et
le Sénat comme par ailleurs les
collectivités locales qui sont les
relais normale en normaux pardon en
démocratie pour faire passer des
messages venant de la base pour conclure
comment vous voyez l'avenir de la droite
et notamment des républicains dans les
années à venir
dans la
si nous arrivons à rétablir en quelque
sorte un décalage entre les
présidentielles et législatives je pense
qu'on pourra faire émerger des hommes de
gouvernement et même des hommes d'État
pour la l'équation présidentielle je
suis pas spécialiste merci beaucoup
Gérard languette d'être venu au micro de
Public Sénat et merci pour votre toutes
ces années de mandat parlementaire merci
merci beaucoup Alexandre et on va
pouvoir commencer à proprement parler
bien le débrief de ces questions au
gouvernement on va commencer par parler
et bien d'un sujet qui a beaucoup marqué
l'actualité du jour c'est la dissolution
des soulèvements de la terre et pour
cela vous êtes avec Sonia baquet
secrétaire d'État mais oui
au sein du ministère de l'Intérieur
Sonia baquet cette dissolution de cette
association de militants écologiste
c'est une solution nécessaire au vu de
la violence de certaines actions
oui dans un
état pliée les associations les
groupements qui engagent et qui
encouragent à des actions violentes qui
a été le cas du des soulèvement de la
terre certains dénoncent une dissolution
politique d'une association qui est
opposée à la politique du gouvernement
notamment en matière agricole est-ce
qu'il y a un choix politique non le
gouvernement procède à des dissolutions
aussi bien pour les groupements
d'ultra-droits d'ultra-goche où là de
mouvement apparentés écologistes là tout
simplement on a des un groupement qui a
appelé à des mots à des actions
violentes près de 400 à 500 personnes
militantes qui ont engagé des actions
violentes Soline 200 à 300 ce weekend
avec 350 armes qui ont été qui ont été
récupérés par les forces de l'ordre on a
clairement des actions violentes qui
sont encouragées par ce groupement on a
passé des aussi à la pression de la
FNSEA le premier syndicat agricole qui
demandait cette dissolution sous peine
d'aller à l'affrontement avec ces
militants écologistes n'a jamais été ne
serait évoqué dans tout le processus de
dissolution qui a été engagée au
contraire on s'est basé sur le droit sur
l'article 212 du code de sécurité
intérieure qui prévoit cette dissolution
en cas d'action violente mais ce que
vous connaissez que dans certaines
manifestations d'agriculteurs il y a
parfois de la violence et pourtant on va
pas dissoudre la FNA
il y a encore une fois on est dans un
état de droit défendre une cause c'est
bien
des gens de la loi
vision c'est normal c'est c'est la règle
encouragée à une action violente
procéder à des actions violentes ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas le droit et dans
ce sens le gouvernement agit est-ce que
vous dites à ces élus qui notamment de
gauche soutiennent cette association les
soulèvements de la terre et parfois
participent à des manifestations
interdites aux côtés de ces militants je
dis tout simplement quand on est un élu
de la République on se doit de respecter
les règles et les lois de la République
et quand on va dans une manifestation
interdite dont on sait qu'elle était
interdite par le préfet avec une
décision qui a été confirmée par le
tribunal administratif quand on est un
élu la République et qu'on va avec son
écharpe on n'est pas la hauteur de ce
mandats écologistes c'est que quand au
bout d'un moment le gouvernement ne fait
pas assez en matière de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique il faut une
certaine forme de désobéissance civile
alors pas nécessairement violente mais
une désobéissance civile pour faire
avancer le combat qu'est-ce que vous
répondez
s'exprimer la liberté d'expression ils
sont dans l'hémicycle ils sont à
l'Assemblée ils peuvent s'exprimer ils
peuvent manifester la France permet
cette liberté et de grandes libertés
mais certainement pas par le biais de la
violence parce que aucune cause ne
mérite la violence